hey there and welcome to the motion
science podcast
my name is cameron and today i am
speaking with a guy by the name of scan
tricky scan is based in belgium he
started as a
print journalist in the early years of
his career
about 12 years ago he fell in love with
motion design
when he came across videos that
graphically
narrated social subjects and today
after years of hard work he is fully
immersed
in motion design and continues to learn
every
single day his goal is to work in
feature films
welcome to the podcast scan tricky
how's it going scan hello how are you
i'm great i'm great how are you doing
really fine really fine great thanks for
being thanks for your attention
yeah thanks yeah i'm really excited to
have you here today scan's got some
some interesting things to show us today
but before we get to that um i want to
ask him
just ask you a few questions yeah um
let's start with
what does a typical day in motion design
look like for you well
my rhythm my daily rhythm it's to
make some client projects to do some
stuff
to test some process some techniques and
to follow
course because i try every day to fill
my
gap to go far away in after effect or
cinema 4d
or houdini and this is my rate every day
and i try every day to
spend one hour if i can't
to learn some new stuff this is my read
with three parts some client projects
tests techniques and learner learn
learn every day so it's very important
for you
every single day that you learn
something
yeah because it's very obsession for me
because at first
like you say i'm a journalist not
a designer so i try every day to fill my
gap
to go really far away in the industry
because i would like to work
for fulfillment so
what do you ultimately want to do in
film
vfx like on the roman design
and fy also because i really love
fy recently i
i did some interface for june
june it's the the new film of danny
villeneuve
and i would like to see to to play
with cinema for the full film for
interfestam for procedural stuff
that is my main goal right now but
i do a lot of stuff for media like
template
like animation for broadcasts with
specific
software like ros expression
rust expression it's a canadian software
from the society ross
and you can do some broadcast animation
with this soft
2d or 3d interesting so
when you say that you're not you're your
background is in journalism
yeah and you're not a so-called designer
how how important is it to you then to
understand
design or is it not important well
when i start to falling in love with
motion design
the main the main complexity
is to know what's motion
and what's design what means this word
and when i started to learn motion
design
i didn't have many course or many
resource
i just need to research
resource to learn this stuff and to know
the software like illustrator
after effect but before that i i know
with a little bit premiere pro photoshop
and audition
because i use it as a journalist for
for in media so
at the first step i learned with uh
lform it's a french platform with uh
an introduction to after effects and
also many tutorials
of uh video co-pilots of andrew kramer
you know
yeah so so then 12 years before
right so then do you find that it's
um through all these tutorials that
you've learned like what makes
a good composition like visually
something needs to look good
it has to have this this and this or how
did you figure that out
well at this point i didn't find any
tutorial about
composition about design i just
try to analyze the other stuff of other
guy
like cal cooper like danny jones like
patrick claire
for main title because i really love
mentally it's one of my goal
to do main title for film for example
because you can do
a lot of stuff like vfx and motion and
uh
and live action in main title and
well i didn't find some course to learn
design principle
so i tried to learn myself
to test something to analyze to try
try and try every day i think that's the
main point it's to practice
of course it's really important but to
to know the technique to know to
practice
each principle you need to do some
exercise
i think that's the main point yeah
also the the other stuff of our great
artists
i totally agree so then what do you find
is
is most challenging for you in terms of
your motion design work
uh it's to know how to
tell a story how to write how to prepare
the workflow and how to prepare the
assets
to to make
a clear story that's the
main challenge for me i know
to write a story for
like an article but it's not the same
process in design
in design there is many many step and
many research
you need first to analyze their id
write the script by the story
mood board then storyboard you need to
sketch every scene to make transition in
every scene to make a logical story
that's a different process like an
article but this is my main challenge i
can do
many techniques i'm i think i'm
can use after effect really really well
i think because i
i use it uh 12 years ago
right now i need to to tell
a good story
that's my main goal right now yeah
so when you set out to make because i've
seen a lot of your artwork that you put
out on social media and a lot of it is
like
single single frames i've seen a lot of
that recently
do you approach designing a single frame
as a story
or how do you approach that what what's
what's your creative
drive behind that for example i test the
environment design
and i would like to take uh to tell
something
in my opinion design some situation and
some atmosphere
but first i tried also to test some
stuff
and some techniques to tell story with
these techniques
i did cover art and still frame
for my own for to test workflow to test
the
software and then i use this technique
to tell story for clients
i see yeah that makes total sense so
so when you started out and
what do you wish that you would have
known when you started out in motion
design years ago if there's one thing
that you could say like
man i wish i would have known this it
would have saved me so much time
is there anything that stands out
well um right now
i i don't want to learn new techniques
in after effect for example but
if i have a project first i
analyzed the projects i analyzed the id
and the story and if i need to learn a
new technique
for this project for this project i
learned it
i don't right now i would like to
to write a good story to make a good
design
and if i learn if i need to learn a
specific workflow
a specific soft i learn it so
every day for example i study now uh
a software called clarisse ifix for vfx
industry
but also i follow some course like the
course process of motion of daniel
danielson
to learn our direction to learn
to understand what's the process how to
compose a good story
this is not the technical part this is
the thinking design part
yeah because you've pretty much you've
mastered a lot of the technical
sides of motion design based upon what
i've seen like you're
you're like a technical master like you
get very detailed
in what you do so it seems like you
already you understand that's
part of it well for my
first years in motion design the main
thing i
i did it's a technical thing
but now after many years of tests
i try to go to the meaning
part that's why i prefer to
to learn our direction and to write a
good story
and then i use technique to tell the
story clearly
awesome so my understanding is that
you've got
a few tips and tricks that you want to
show us today
so yeah so let's let's dive into that i
have
a little procedural technique on after
effects
based on two main principle
first fractal noise and then shape layer
so i can show you
my screen okay well for my first
example i would like to see this
procedural hut for interface design for
example
but based on a simple fractal noise as
you see here i just have one layer
with few effects based first on the
fractal noise
i can show you first the fractal noise
you see
yeah this is just a fractal noise
in block mode
noise type block mode so
i make a little expression to offset
automatically the turbulence and the
evolution with time
and also a time but in
position y and you see
yeah i have a automatic load evolution
of my fractal noise then
i put other and other effects for
example for the symmetry
i use cc caleda for kaleidoscopic effect
effects then to
extract here the black parts
i use lumaki for an alpha channel
you see here i have my alpha channel
like that then i use to have a circle
like a head-up display polar coordinates
then transform to reduce the scale
of my shape then to have a little dots
in all of the grey scale texture
i use sysible action
then triton for the color then fine edge
you see the
the difference between this one
and file edge i have a little bit
stroke here that's why
i use the luma key you see because
if i don't use the luma key i have this
texture when i use luma key for alpha
channel
i have a gap i prefer that
yeah when then for the
for the last effects of this kind of
image
i use glow for a little bit light
and when i play it's a procedural
texture
wow and it's really it's really perfect
for
interface animation
when you need a rudder of a data
all kind of stuff i have
other example for example here based
also
on the fractal noise you see here
i have first my
background then my grid
and i use here the effects
fill in black my grid lumaki
because with rumaki i can have my
my alpha channel then cc ball
for this little dot then curve
for luminance then the grid
based on fractal noise the same setup
but for none of that case you see here i
have my fractal noise
posterize to just
extract the white data then mosaic
with the same value
of the grid here okay
so what so what does the mosaic do
the mosaic it's a pixelize
the effects like a little square for
all of your composition because when i
deactivate mosaic you see
here you see the gap here
and when activate mosaic i have perfect
square okay
in the corner then i continue with fine
edge
lumaki to extract
the the black part
and glow and that's it the last example
i have this one
same setup with fractal noise here
posterize to simplify the texture you
see
difference between with
posterize and without posterize
then lumaki to extract my alpha channel
and then add this effect stroke
that's why i pull off the white
background to add a stroke here
and procedural stroke you see
then color gradients and a little bit
transform to reduce the scale of my
shape
now what would you use this uh in you
know in in
the ui elements like what would
something like this be used for
i if you want for example
to uh to make an analyze box
or a background an animated background
you can use this process okay i can show
you
a few examples on my dribble icons
because i prepare some example
just voila
people can download this file for
interface design
you see oh yeah you have your head up
display you have grid
full procedural very cool
and if you if you
write interfs design fui for example i
can show you something
for example you have this head-up
display
see you have grid here
you can compose a procedural a
procedural grid
for this stuff i can show you also
other thing this one i did
this head up display in 3d with element
3d and also after effect you see all the
function
you see all the little line here like
hard too fast design it's fractal noise
only fractal noise so you don't see and
it's fully procedural so you don't
you don't need illustrator for this
shape
for example if i want to to compose
this little detail it's really really
simple so
let me show you something in five
minutes so
head up display i take my solids
to reduce my comp
and in 10 seconds for example
first i use fractal noise
block mode i set up something
voila i scale up the transformation
like that for example
then i use cc caleda
and polar coordinates
here for example
envola then if you need lines
you can take fine edge
and you see here yeah then you can use
lumaki to extract
the black part here you can increase
threshold and that's it
wow so simple but so powerful yeah and
here when you increase also the light
for example
with the curve or level as you wish
voila and
a little bit glow to add
some luminance
hey if you need another design i just
take the transform tool
above
lunaki and that's it if you need another
design
for your head up display you can just
play with
evolution you see
and i can use also posterize to simplify
my
texture like that and you see i have my
line
a clear line like that yeah and if i
need another design
i don't need vector in illustrator i
just need
like that and i can scale it's fully
procedural
you see yeah
that is really cool yeah it's just based
on fractal noise and you
you can see each step first cc collider
polar coordinate posterize
fine edge luma key and
the other three effects and that's it
you have your other display
fully procedural wow
and that's why that's why i have this
little detail here
sure yeah
for the second example it's based on
shape layer you see here i just
have one shape layer without any effects
it's just native transformation option
in the shape layer
so first i have a simple square
just a square little square here a
square with
fill and stroke then i repeat
this square with the
the repeater option i repeat
again to have a grid then i use
wiggle transformation and i have my
fractal noise
my noise sorry
but without keyframe you see i have if i
press u
i don't have any keyframe because this
effects
wiggle transformation it's fully
procedural also
and you can manage your correlation
your rotation here
your scale also you see if i want to
scale like that
there are also any keyframe the second
example
it's the same method but
here with another combination
for example i have a
simple ellipse trim path stroke so you
see a level just a lit
a simple stroke here with the wrong
corner
then i use repeat
then i offset the path to create this
shape then wiggle transformation
you see without keyframe then i repeat
again and i play also with the opacity
value
here then i wiggle again my shape
and the last effects it's gradient for
color
nice i have another other example like
here
i have like a 3d corridor you see a fake
3d corridor
it's really simple so i have my
my square my little little
square here you see it's really really
tiny the ingredients
then repeat you see
then wiggle and with the wiggle
transformation you can use
this option temporal phase and special
feather with a little
expression it's really simple with time
expression
and then you can feel again
to add some color this saturation and
that's it
so for the repeater are you just doing a
scale repeater
yeah exactly you see here a scalar
cool you see here yeah up in my skill
voila it's really simple setup
and you can compose
this kind of effect fully procedural on
after effect of course you can use also
the new software cavalry
for procedural vector but
for this kind of stuff in in after
effects it's really possible and really
powerful and i have also this example
same same process you see
with just con this
voila
and i have my stroke here you see just
simple square i continue to deform my
square with a packer and bloat effects
then i offset my path to create a cross
then i merge all of my shape here
and i repeat my shape like that then i
wiggle
all of my shape
to have a a kind of vertigo
then i use gradient fill to create
to create this field between the stroke
yeah
and the last example this one just
for regular effects
and you can use this kind of stuff in
oblivion
in the interface of ghost in the shell
of bloodrunner there is a lot of
of design like that but here
the difference it's fully procedural
it's not making illustrator an animate
in after effects it's fully procedural
that's the main difference
so what they did in like blade runner
was that procedural then
or do you know well uh
i know one of the designer called nick
hill he designed
many interface for bloodrunner and he
explained me
uh the main process at territory studio
it's a steel frame in illustrator
texture in photoshop
and animation in after effect if
territory use procedural way
sometimes it's with cinema 4d
but there is no many many
assets in procedural stuff only in after
effects
i don't know why but for my interface
design
like the interface for dune i use this
technique for my own
and i prefer to use it for example
in illustrator i just design
the main box the main shape the constant
shape
of the interface and for each elements
in animation i use just after effects
because i have this procedural way
and it's really simple to update you
just need to go to the option
and update the data
with your art director and that's it
yeah really simple yeah i prefer to use
this way because it's really simple to
update
each little part for example if you need
to add
a path here you can just add a path
draw something and you see
if i draw something
it's fully dynamic
and it's just a square yeah that's
really cool
i prefer this way yeah and i noticed
that you use
um glow a lot do you find yourself
using the built-in after effects glow
or is there another glow that you like
to use uh you have
the plug-in deeper glow if i get a
mistake
but for my needs
in interface design usually we use
we us we just use the glow or
the plugin of video co-pilots for
example i can
check i can use that the plug-in cc free
prints
you see this one
three brands it's kind of glow
see here
but usually we we use just the glow
effects because a territory studio
there is a lot of software for example
territory studio don't use element 3d
but they use red giant
series but not element ready because
it's not the process for example
if a territory studio need a multi-pass
in 3d they use after effects they render
the object with you passed specular pass
also
color path also and they make the
compositing in after effects so they
don't they don't use
3d element because this is not the
process
a territory studio perhaps in the future
i don't know but right now it's not the
main plugin
for example so when you said that they
use red giant
what plugins do they use from red giant
um the
um the
shape uh the particle
uh also the
i forgot the plexus effect
also okay uh also universe
yeah and
and the last
tool for landscape
oh mirror mirror exactly
yes for 3d objects and for plexus
effects yeah i'm a huge fan
of uh universe style or the universe
plans
yeah they're very powerful well scan
that was uh that was awesome to see your
process there of how you work with
procedural
uh animation and and design procedurally
it's really cool
um is there anything else that you want
to add before we wrap up this interview
well i just shared the source file for
students who would like to play with
this kind of stuff
and to check also each effect
each little option and
if you have any question if a student
have any question
don't hesitate to to ping me in social
media
sure so now if someone wants to find you
on social media where is the best place
to find you
well i love to share stuff in my dribble
icons
you can add me also in facebook or in
twitter and
that's it i i don't have a site i have
my showreel
in vimeo but
my main test page it's in dribble
okay awesome so i will link to your
dribble page in the description below
the video so that anyone who wants to
find you they will be able to find you
um thanks man and i appreciate you so
much being on the show today
it was awesome to talk to you and to
hear your information
so um as always thanks for being here
man
and uh that wraps up this episode of the
motion science podcast
[Music]
you